hmm ladies and gentlemen welcome to all
of you the president of the Commission
will now make a statement following the
college adoption of the Green Deal this
is a press statement the president will
not be taking questions President the
floor is yours this is a very special
day this morning the College of
Commissioners agreed on the European
Green Deal the European Green Deal is on
one hand our vision for a climate
neutral continent in 2050 and it's on
the under other hand a very dedicated
road map to this goal it's kind of 50
actions for 2050 our goal is to
reconcile the economy with our planet to
reconcile the way we produce the way we
consume with our planet and to make it
work for our people
therefore the European Green Deal is on
one hand about cutting emissions but on
the other hand about creating jobs and
boosting and innovation I'm convinced
that the old growth model that is based
on fossil fuels and pollution is out of
date and it is out of touch with our
planet the European Green Deal is our
new growth strategy it's a strategy for
growth that gives more back than it
takes away and we want to really make
things different we want to be the
frontrunners in climate friendly
industries in clean technologies in
green financing but we also have to be
sure that no one is
behind in other words this transition
will either be working for all and be
just or will not work at all and
therefore a crucial part in the European
Green Deal is the just transition
mechanism we have the ambition to
mobilize 100 billion euros precisely
targeted to the most vulnerable regions
and sectors the European Green Deal is a
broad roadmap we care also about
biodiversity and forests agriculture and
food green cities and for example the
circular economy we do not have all the
answers yet today is the start of a
journey but this is europe's man on the
moon moment the European Green Deal is
very ambitious but it will also be very
careful in assessing the impact and
every single step we're taking the
European Green Deal is an invitation for
all to participate I mean European
citizens are changing their lifestyle to
protect the country the climate and the
planet therefore our European Green Deal
tells them that Europe is at their side
the European Green Deal is something I'm
convinced we owe to our children because
we do not own this planet we just do
have a certain for a certain time the
responsibility and now it's time to act
thank you very much I'm now running to
Parliament I will present there the
European Green Deal with France
timmermans to Parliament then tomorrow I
will present the European Green Deal to
our leaders and the European Council
and from steamer months will present the
European Green Deal at cop 25 in Madrid
thank you very much thank you very much
[Music]
you